I love wearing boots the rest of that
sounds really awful
you give Disney Channel a good name dub
Camryn you doubled up and live in Mattie
and you bridge the gap between hero and
villain in The Descendants franchise if
every Disney star could be as half as
successful as you they'd be set for life
you've put acting on the back burner to
pursue a career in music and you're
making waves in the industry but some of
your co-stars have already gone on to
shut the Disney Channel title
celebrities come and go but these 15
former Disney stars are forever
you won't believe which actors have
finally managed to break out of the
Disney mold often Butler Austin Butler
has accomplished so much since leaving
the Disney Channel family it's hard to
remember him ever being a part of it at
all
Austin first appeared in Hannah Montana
in 2006 and would go on to guest star on
TV shows like the Zeke and Luther Jonas
and Wizards of Waverly Place Austin is
one of the many actors who have starred
on both Disney Channel and Nickelodeon
TV shows but those days are in the past
since leaving Disney Austin has starred
in TV series arrow and the shannara
chronicles' today he's all set to play
Elvis Presley in the 2021 Elvis Presley
project in fact the only thing linking
him to his Disney days is his longtime
girlfriend Vanessa Hudgens debby ryan
debby ryan will forever be known as a
Disney Channel fan favorite okay even I
don't believe that but her reputation
doesn't end there she's one of the few
actors who has managed to break out of
the disney child star mold and she's
only getting started
debby ryan reigned supreme as the
titular character from the disney sitcom
Jessie but before that she played bailey
pickett
on the suite life on deck nowadays
however you probably know her as patty
ladle from the hit Netflix series
insatiable although this series has
received a lot of backlash for its
controversial TV plots fans just can't
get enough of it ditching our Disney
title wasn't easy and it took years of
hard work but it was nothing Debbie
couldn't handle Bella Thorne Bella
Thorne might only be 22 years old but
she's got an impressive acting
background she was a successful actor
before starring on Disney Channel's
shake it off so we're not at all
surprised that she's made a name for
herself outside of the platform too
Bella is busy with new projects would be
an understatement
just take a look at her IMDB page and
see for yourself the girl is booked
Bella have a hard time respecting the
Disney Channels rulebook
she had a controversial image and
struggled to fit in since leaving Disney
Bella has starred in movies like the
Deaf and amityville The Awakening Ross
Lynch
he's talented he's adorable and he's no
longer the Disney Channel star he used
to be Ross Lynch has moved on from
portraying the musically talented Austin
moon on Disney Channel's Austin and Ally
and that wasn't an easy thing to
accomplish starring in the 2017 film my
friend Dahmer
really helped Ross drop the Disney
Channel title that had attached itself
to his name and just one year later in
2018 Ross landed the role of Harvey
kinkle on the beloved Netflix original
series chilling Adventures of Sabrina
Ross continues to impress us with his
versatile acting skills his fans love
how he can play the hero the victim and
the villain without missing a beat
Chyna and McClain Chyna and McClain does
the Disney Channel proud as one of the
most talented triple threats in the
industry she's been acting since she was
a little girl and she's been cast
alongside household names like Adam
Sandler Salma Hayek and cress Williams
Chyna stole the spotlight as uma and The
Descendants franchise and they've kept
it all for themselves but she also
starred in the Disney Channel sitcom ant
farm
since leaving the Disney family Chyna
has snagged a lead role in the TV series
Black Lightning in which she portrays
Jennifer Pierce aka lightning this
leading lady is so successful she
quickly ditched the house of mouse named
China has recently been cast in the
star-studded cast of hubby Halloween
keep watching to find out which one of
China's descendants co-stars has also
managed to shake the Disney image Selena
Gomez most Millennials know who Selena
Gomez is and their parents due to that's
just how popular the former Disney star
has become Selena has been acting since
2003 she first appeared in Barney &
Friends and was quickly welcomed into
the Disney Channel family she's best
known for starring as Alex Russo on
Wizards of Waverly Place but that seems
like ages ago when you take her bustling
career into account
Selena has managed to excel in both
acting and singing which isn't an easy
thing to do she's one of the most
Buhler pop stars in the world and she's
a famed voiceover actor to having voiced
Mavis in the Hotel Transylvania
franchise in 2016 Selena was cast as
that and fundamentals of caring she also
portrayed the Phi lambda president's and
neighbors two sorority rising Cole
Sprouse Cole Sprouse and his twin
brother Dylan have been staples in the
industry ever since they portrayed
little Ben on friends but they will go
on to become two of the most well-known
Disney stars of all time this is thanks
to their shows The Suite Life of Zack
and Cody and the suite life on deck
ditching a title like this one isn't
something the average actor can do but
Coleman is to do just that when he was
cast as Jughead Jones in Riverdale then
in 2019 Cole also snagged the lead role
of will in the dramatic romantic comedy
five feet apart before we continue if we
want to encourage you to subscribe to
the things we post daily videos about
the hottest movies TV shows and to labs
so turn on those notifications so you
never miss another video if you're
watching on your phone switch up your
YouTube settings to get notified as soon
as we post something new now let's get
back to everyone's favorite Disney
Channel stars zendaya coleman zendaya is
the epitome of success she's an actor
dancer singer model and activist she
first made waves in the Disney Channel
when she was cast as rocky blue and
shake it up alongside bella thorne just
when we thought Disney has lost her for
good she came back to star as KC Cooper
in KC Undercover but it didn't take long
for his India to put her Disney Channel
days behind her in fact she accomplished
this one year before KC undercover aired
its series finale in 2017 Scindia was
cast as Michelle in spider-man
homecoming and she would reprise her
role as MJ in the 2019 blockbuster film
spider-man far from home this actor has
got a lot of range which is something
she is proven by starring as Ruth
Bennett in euphoria Nicholas bran
Nicholas Brown played Zach in the Disney
movies sky high in 2005 and in 2009 he
portrayed Edie in the Disney Channel
Original Movie princess protection
program if you're having a hard time
placing him it's probably because he did
such an amazing job
at leaving his Disney Channel days
behind him Nicholas would go on to star
alongside Dakota Johnson rebel Wilson
and Leslie Mann in the 2016 movie how to
be single in which he played Alice's
ex-boyfriend Josh but that's not all
Nicholas has accomplished the former
Disney actor starred as Craig in the TV
show succession he's also ready to steal
the show as will in the big ugly
Peyton list if you were a fan of the
Disney show bunked chances are you're an
even bigger fan of Peyton lists this
talented young lady was always meant for
the limelight and her Disney Channel
past was the last thing that was going
to stop her from making it big more
powerful than a platinum charge the
Jesse star made a name for herself when
she portrayed Ciara in anthem of a
teenage prophet and just like China and
McClain she's all set to star in hubby
Halloween 2020 is going to be a busy
year for the actor turned singer her
IMDB page is stacked with upcoming
projects and her music career is already
making headlines Shia LaBeouf Shia
LaBeouf quickly ditched the wholesome
Disney Channel image and opted for
something up entirely different he's an
eccentric actor who manages to keep
Hollywood on its toes but his
controversial ways have never stopped
him from landing big-time roles Shia got
his big break when he played Lewis
Stevens
on the Disney Channel sitcom even
Stephens from 2000 to 2003 but as Disney
Channel days would quickly become old
news
Shia has started movies like iRobot
disturbia and the greatest game ever
played but he's most famously recognized
for portraying Sam Witwicky in the
Transformers franchise oh yeah and let's
not forget about his hilariously
ridiculous just do it video Zac Efron
much to his dismay Zac Efron will
forever be remembered as Troy Bolton
from the High School Musical franchise
but that's not all he'll be remembered
for after all he did manage to graduate
from his Disney Channel days with flying
colors
zach is a triple threat who has starred
in musical productions like hairspray
and the greatest showman but he kicked
his wholesome Disney image to the curb
by starring in comedies like dirty
grandpa and neighbours one and two in
2017 Zach starred as Matt Brody in the
blockbuster film Baywatch a lot of fans
believe that zach has been typecast as
the golden boy until he switched things
up by starring in
Stream Li wicked shockingly evil and
vile sterling night
sterling night is one of those classic
Disney Channel stars having starred and
sunny with a chance alongside Demi
Lovato but he wouldn't be pegged as a
Disney child actor forever sterling
would go on to play Xander Carlsen on
Melissa & Joey and he would even star
alongside Zac Efron in the 2009 film
seventeen again like most of his former
co-stars sterling is a triple threat
he'll show off his range as Randy van
Ronson in the 20/20 TV show
Katie keen Sophia Carson Sophia Carson
might have gotten her start on the 2015
Disney Channel movie descendants but she
quickly left the franchise behind her
when production wrapped up in 2019 sure
she'll forever be the one and only Evie
but she's so much more than that on top
of becoming a pop star Sofia has gone on
to model for prestigious brands but that
isn't too surprising considering her
beauty before Sofia had her foot out of
the Disney Channel door she had already
been cast as Ava Jalali in the TV series
Pretty Little Liars the perfectionist
Sofia makes ditching the Disney name
look easy Miley Cyrus but the most
popular former Disney star award goes to
Miley Cyrus this talented lady has been
making headlines
ever since she landed the lead role in
Disney's Hannah Montana but being a part
of the Disney Channel family wasn't
always easy for Miley which is why she
never looked back after leaving the
network Miley's music career is off the
charts she's made a name for herself as
one of the best pop stars of her
generation music is her passion but she
enjoys acting when a certain project
calls out to her like in 2019 when Miley
starred as Ashley O in an episode of
Black Mirror and that's a wrap are we
missing anyone which of their actors
managed to ditch the Disney name sound
off in the comments thanks for watching
the things give this video a big thumbs
up and don't forget to subscribe for
more who we'll see you next time
you